alors alors alors l'avion bien plus d'un
trop longue la l'avion ça dit quoi
écoutez moi comme beaucoup de gens j'ai
peur en avion mais lucas ses moyens
transport le plus sûr je m'en fous c'est
le moyen de transport aussi un crash
tu es mort bien sûr j'angoisse du crash
parce que s'il arrive je suis mort il ya
beaucoup plus de décès par exemple dans
des accidents de voiture hockey soit
mais il ya aussi beaucoup d'accidents
voiture où il n'ya pas de mort et où les
blessures sont mineures
j'ai tort d'avoir peur de l'avion je le
sais mais j'ai quand même peur c'est un
truc que je maîtrise pas ma vie elle est
entre les mains d'un équipage que je
connais pas moi je sais pas ce qu'ils
ont fait la veille et l'appareil
il est vérifié par des gars je sais pas
moi ça arrive à tout le monde de type
d'être un peu étourdi pendant 20
secondes
bon je suis parano je suis méga parano
je sais que c'est ma transport le plus
sûr surtout en 2020 qui a très très très
peu de gens qui décèdent ou qui sont
blessés à cause d'un crash ou d'un vol
d'avion je sais tout ça mais sauf qu'à
une autre époque c'était pas aussi
sécurisé que maintenant je vous parle
par exemple des années 70 aux battues en
se marrant ce l'usiné ou des options de
porsche
bref j'étais un peu toutes les histoires
où ce qu'il ya autour de crash d'avion
les histoires où en gros un avion chute
de plusieurs kilomètres et il ya un ou
plusieurs survivants ce qui est
incroyable
en france le crash d'avion le plus
médiatisé ça a sans doute été l'histoire
du vol 626 de yemenia qui s'est
malheureusement cracher dans l'océan
indien et tout le monde est décédée sauf
une personne
et le pire c'est que c'était il ya
seulement 11 ans donc la technologie et
la sécurité avait déjà bien avancé
aujourd'hui je pas trop envie combat des
consommatrices tous vis-à-vis des avions
donc on va parler comme pour actionne
parc d'histoire qu'ont lieu dans les
années 70 de deux histoires commenter
mon attention tous ceux qui tissent les
faits divers les petites histoires à
droite à gauche vous les connaissez
peut-être soyez pas votre voisin si vous
regardez la vidéo à plusieurs
attention la première histoire c'est
probablement la plus dingue que ya eu
autour d'un crash d'avion ça s'est passé
dans les années 70 il ya eu un film est
sorti en 1993 qui s'appelle les
survivants et qui retrace exactement
l'histoire de ce crash et tout ce qui
s'en est suivie puisque c'est à durer
des semaines
franchement c'est celle qui donne le
plus d'espoir parce que beaucoup de
survivants en vrai mais d'un autre côté
qui est très malade parce qu'elle montre
qu'il faut se battre pour s'en sortir
bref on y brasse et le wolf wales à haïr
et à ouroux gouaille à 571 ça se passe
dans les années 70 quand je vous ai dit
on est précisément le 13 octobre 1972 ce
volailles par de montevideo en uruguay
direction santiago au chili et à son
bord et
à toute une équipe de rugby le hall
christiane ce club de montevideo qui
doit disputer prochainement un match au
chili à bord de l'appareil se trouve
aussi les proches des membres de
l'équipe de rugby ce qui amène le total
de nombre de passagers à 40
sans compter bien entendu les cinq
membres d'équipage le vol se passe très
bien l'avion est en train de passer au
dessus de la cordillère des andes qui
est une chaîne de montagne très
imposante mais le pilote fait une énorme
erreur responsable du crash l'avion est
à bonne altitude dans les nuages il n'y
a pas de visibilité mais le pilote c'est
comme se glissent trouve la fameuse
chaîne de montagne sauf que ce jour là
il va amorcer sa descente trop tôt à
cause d'un vent de face qui fait que
l'appareil allait moins vite
le pilote s'aperçoit qu'il est alors au
milieu de la chaîne de montagne et il
essaie de remonter mais c'est trop tard
l'appareil a alors percuté un premier
pic de glaciers qui va tout simplement
lui arracher les droites et la queue
dans laquelle se trouve une partie des
passagers bien entendu suite à sa
l'avion ne peut plus reprendre de
l'altitude et se sortir de là et va même
heurté un deuxième pic de glaciers qui
va cette fois arraché l'ailé gauche du
coup il ya plus que le corps de l'avion
sont là que qui chute dans la montagne
et et atterrit dans la neige et qui
glisse sur plusieurs centaines de mètres
avant que naturellement s'arrêter le
corps de l'avion et donc sur un glacier
à 3600 mètres d'altitude à côté c'est
mieux ça que de tomber 3600 mètres de
l'autre côté c'est les pires conditions
bilan du crash
neuf passagers meurent à l'impact dont
les passagers qui étaient dans la queue
de l'appareil
mais quand même 33 survivants c'est
énorme
le chili l'uruguay et l'argentine savent
que l'appareil s'est crashé dans les
montagnes et met tout en oeuvre pour
essayer de retrouver l'appareil et de
venir au secours des passagers
malheureusement l'avion il est blanc et
il est à 3600 mètres d'altitude dans de
la neige ce qui le rend parfaitement
invisible
vu du ciel sachez que le commun des
mortels à 2500 mètres passait d'altitude
a des problèmes c'est vraiment selon
l'organisme de chacun et même si tu as
un corps très sain en bonne santé tu
peux avoir des vertiges ton cerveau pas
assez alimenté en oxygène bref c'est
super dangereux
l'autre souci aussi c'est qui fait très
froid à 3600 m à ce moment là dans ces
montagnes là la nuit la température peut
baisser et avoisiner les -30 degrés des
premiers jours ils vont être malin et
rassembler tous les stocks de nourriture
qui a dans l'avion mais c'est pas grand
chose c'est des sucreries du chocolat un
peu d'alcool
il n'y a pas de vrai repas n'y a pas de
quoi tenir longtemps mais ils sont
prévoyants ils ont très vite compris
l'environnement dans lequel ils étaient
et savent que s'ils veulent survivre
lors essentiel problème avec la
nourriture
la première nuit trois de nos survivants
vont malheureusement perdre la vie des
séquelles de leurs blessures il y aura
un mort aussi le deuxième jour est le
huitième jour les survivants sont
vraiment malin je trouve par rapport à
la situation dans laquelle il se trouve
et ils vont mettre toutes les chances de
leurs
côté en organisant des expéditions
malheureusement à cause des conditions
climatiques ça peut pas être des grandes
expéditions mais y'en a qui partent
quand même à plusieurs kilomètres de la
dépouille dans l'espoir de trouver de
l'aide
fernando par ado lors de son expédition
tombe sur la queue de l'avion qui
s'était détaché malheureusement il n'y a
aucun survivant mais il ya juste un
appareil photo que fernando va récupérer
et avec lequel il va photographier la
vie quotidienne du groupe pendant
plusieurs semaines vous vous en doutez
au fil des jours les stocks de
nourriture baissent il n'y a pas de
nouvelles nourritures puisqu'il ya
aucune forme de vie aux alentours du
coup nos survivants sont dans la merde
fernando par ado explique alors aux
groupes que il songe à manger le corps
du pilote pour ne pas mourir de faim
corps du pilote qui grâce à la neige et
à la température est parfaitement
conservés après une grande discussion
les survivants comprennent que leur
seule chance de survivre c'est de faire
ça ils vont donc tous décidé de se
nourrir du corps des victimes et vont
faire une sorte de pacte entre eux qui
stipule que si l'un d'eux meurt entre
temps les hôtes ont le droit de le
manger
honnêtement qui sommes nous pour juger
je sais pas du tout ce que j'aurais fait
à leur place
onze jours après le crash roj harley
apprend grâce à la radio de l'avion
qu'ils ont entre-temps réparé et que les
recherches ont été abandonnées par les
autorités malgré ça le groupe va pas se
décourager l'instinct de survie il est
là et multiplie les expéditions toujours
dans l'espoir de tomber sur l'aide d'une
quelconque forme dead c'est un
environnement hyper hostile qui
malheureusement réduit fortement leurs
chances de tomber sur de l'aide et qui
est aussi cause d'autres problèmes comme
par exemple au 17e jour lorsqu'une
avalanche s'abat sur la dépouille de
l'avion entraînant la mort de huit de
nos survivants
cet enchaînement de malchance est dingue
ça fait deux mois que nos survivants
sont là et comprennent que le seul moyen
pour eux de s'en sortir c'est d'aller
chercher à l'aide parce que personne ne
se doute qu'il ya des survivants et
personne va lancer des recherches pour
les aider le 12 décembre
fernando par ado roberto canessa et
antonio visentin s'équipent des
vêtements les plus chauds prennent le
plus gros de la réserve de nourriture et
s'embarque dans une expédition très
lointaine dans le but d' enfin trouver
de l'aide
malheureusement le troisième jour de
cette expédition antonio glisse et se
blesse ce qui l'obligé à retourner à
l'épave et a laissé ses deux camarades
continuent l'expédition sans lui le 20
décembre après une expédition de huit
jours
fernando et roberto aperçoit au loin des
prairies vertes et il tombe enfin sur un
être humain en l'occurrence un paysan
qui s'appelle sergio catalan il lui
explique qui ils sont et ce qui leur est
arrivé et sergio va taper ses meilleures
heures de cheval en direction des
autorités pour les prévenir les
autorités décident alors dans
et deux hélicoptères militaires guidé
par fernando hélicoptère qui vont enfin
trouver le lieu du crash
fernando et roberto graff gérer ils ont
réussi après dix jours d'efforts à enfin
trouver de l'aide sur nos 33 survivants
à l'impact y en a seulement du coup 16
qui sont arrivés au bout des deux mois
mais ce qui reste énorme je trouve ça
dingue cette capacité qu'ils ont eu à
réfléchir à s'adapter à comprendre ce
qui leur arrivait à mettre toutes les
chances de leur côté et ils ont même dû
faire des choix horrible sous peine de
ne pas échapper à l'issue logique des
choses à savoir mourir de famine c'est
assez dingue et fernando du coup le mâle
alpha du groupe il a sorti un livre du
coup en 2006 qui s'appelle les
survivants dans les andes et c'est le
premier du coup de tous les survivants à
avoir témoigné à l'écrit dans une oeuvre
de ce qui leur est arrivé
je crois c'est l'un des rares crash
d'avion il ya eu autant de survivants et
ou du coup il pouvait réfléchir en
groupe en fait où il n'était pas victime
de la solitude et de la folie du coup
que ça implique d'être sol je suis
certain que c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
réussi à survivre aussi longtemps c'est
qu'ils étaient vraiment nombreux je sais
pas c'est assez intéressant c'est assez
unique en fait comme crash
bref voilà histoire très connu mais
vraiment incroyable seconde histoire
c'est tout aussi incroyable mais c'est
très différent
c'est aussi peut-être une histoire de
vous avez entendu parler tant aller
miraculeuse c'est l'histoire de julian
coop petit bagram d'abord julien né en
1954 à lima la capitale du pérou et ses
parents travaillent au musée d'histoire
naturelle en 1968 quand elle a 14 ans et
décide de créer pangwoh une station de
recherche biologique en pleine forêt
amazonienne
ils veulent étudier la faune et la flore
et du coup julian devient ce qu'on
appelle une enfant sauvage c'est à dire
une enfant qui est scolarisé à domicile
et son père lui apprend des tas de
techniques de survie dans le milieu dans
lequel ils sont à savoir la jungle
petite élise dans le temps né en 1971
julian est sur le point de terminer ces
fameuses études si sa dernière année
elle va savoir si elle a passé ou dans
l'examen sa mère et passage à lima mais
elle souhaite retourner à bangoura n'a
pour rejoindre son père le 19 au 20
décembre
mais julian ne veux pas parce que le 23
décembre c'est sa cérémonie de remise
des diplômes
elle aimerait que sa mère y assistent
maria sa maman est une très bonne mère
et du coup elle accepte la requête de
julian et elle décide donc de décaler
son vol au 23 au soir pour rejoindre son
mari et passer noël avec eux
malheureusement on est dans la période
de noël et tous les vols sont pleins
sauf un vol c'est celui opéré par la
compagnie lineas aereas national ssr et
s'il est pas complet c'est parce que
c'est une compagnie qui a une très
mauvaise réputation qui venait très
récemment de perdre deux avions dans des
crashs
on est donc le 23 décembre mais mariage
bel et bien à la cérémonie de remise des
diplômes de julian après laquelle elles
se rendent à l'aéroport et montrent bel
et bien dans l'avion qui est censé les
emmenait à puch alpes à l'aéroport le
plus proche de pang ouanna là où se
trouve le père de julien alors c'est pas
un grand vol 1 s'est même pas très loin
c'est à seulement une heure et le
premier tiers du vol se passe très bien
aucun problème au décollage et aucun
problème pendant précisément 25 minutes
à ce moment là l'avion traverse des
nuages noirs très épais et il se met à
trembler dans tous les sens il faut
savoir qu'un avion même encore
aujourd'hui tu peux te retrouver dans
des turbulences qui font que ça bouge
mais un truc de malade
écoutez ça m'est arrivé quand je dis que
je me suis fait chier dessus le mot est
faible
là les secousses dont parle julian c'est
des turbulences énorme c'est les
turbulences où tu sais qu'il ya un
problème d'un coup il ya un énorme flash
blanc dans l'avion et il se met à piquer
du nez ce qui vient de se passer c'est
qu'il ya un éclair qui a touché le
réservoir de carburant de l'aisne
ce qui a eu comme conséquence d'arracher
leur la vue est en train de piquer du
nez et julian se souvient d'objets de
noël qui volaient partout dans la cabine
le tout sous les cris des passagers ses
derniers souvenirs qu'à julian avant de
célébrer elle se réveille un peu plus
tard dans le silence et cette fois il ya
plus un bruit
à part le bruit du vent qui sifflent
dans ses oreilles elle réalise qu'elle
est toujours attaché à son siège mais
qu'elle est en pleine chute libre qu'il
ya plus d'avions autour d'elle elle est
tout seul
à trois kilomètres du sol en train de
tourner sur elle-même elle va rapidement
se ré évanouir à cause de la chute en
fait l'avion s'est disloqué
ce qui fait que plein de ranger se sont
détachés de l'appareil et sont tombés
dans le vide plus tard julian se
réveille de nouveau et elle comprend
immédiatement qu'elle vient de survivre
à un crash d'avion ce qu'elle sait pas
encore c'est que c'est la seule
passagère qui a survécu
les 91 autres sont décédés on apprendra
plus tard qu'apparemment elle a survécu
parce qu'elle a atterri dans une partie
hyper dense de la forêt et que y'a plein
plein plein de branches et de feuilles
qui ont amorti sa chute julian se
réveille donc elle regarde sa montre et
il est 9 heures du matin elle vient donc
de passer presque 20 heures inconsciente
elle entend d'ailleurs au dessus d'elle
des bruits de moteurs qui sont en fait
des avions qui cherche le lieu du crash
et de potentiel survivant
malheureusement comme pour l'autre vol
la forêt est très dense et vu du ciel on
ne voit rien à cause des feuilles des
arbres
julien vient de faire une chute libre de
3 km et pourtant elle n'a que des
blessures mineures
ce qui est incroyable son premier
réflexe ça va être de crier le prénom de
sa mère dans l'espoir de la retrouver
mais après avoir créé pendant un moment
elle n'a toujours pas de réponse elle
franck est les seuls à l'endroit où elle
a atterri à ce moment là elle a un peu
repris ses esprits elle découvre qu'elle
ne voit plus que d'un oeil
parce que les différences de pression
entre l'intérieur et l'extérieur de
l'avion ont fait exploser ses capillaire
oculaire tout simplement
et bien entendu dans le crash elle a
perdu ses lunettes donc elle voit très
très mal à ce moment-là julian elle a de
la chance dans son malheur c'est qu'elle
connaît la forêt elle connaît la jambe
c'est pas un milieu qui lui est hostile
contrairement à vous ou moi par exemple
bref julien se lève et se met à marcher
dans l'espoir de trouver d'autres
survivants
elle va marcher une journée entière
avant de tomber sur la dépouille de
l'appareil dans laquelle malheureusement
sur les sièges restants tous les
passagers sont décédés mais dans
laquelle elle va trouver un paquet de
bonbons qui va lui être très utile
puisqu'elle n'a aucune nourriture avec
elle rapidement julian tombe sur une
crique un point d'eau elle suit donc son
cours d'eau et décide de marcher dans
l'eau parce qu'elle sait que c'est plus
sûr que de marcher sur la terre hewitt
sur la terre il ya des plantes toxiques
il ya des serpents qui sont cachés il ya
des insectes venimeux et elle veut
mettre toutes les chances de son côté
c'est un réflexe par exemple que
j'aurais jamais petit ellipses on est
dix jours après le crash julian est
toujours en vie mais elle est très
faible se déplaçait devient de plus en
plus dure à tel point qu'elle arrive à
peine à tenir debout
en plus de ça il a une plaie au bras qui
s'est infectée c'est à dire qu'il ya des
insectes qui ont pondu des oeufs dedans
et qu'elle a maintenant des asticots qui
vivent dans son bras et qui se
nourrissent de sa chair c'est horrible
c'est notre phobie à tous
elle s'est lui est arrivé son état la
pousse à prendre la décision de se
laisser porter par le courant d'une
rivière plutôt que de marcher de
dépenser de l'énergie
ce qu'elle n'a quasiment plus plus tard
cette rivière va l'amener à tomber sur
un gros bateau en voyant ce bateau
julian va d'abord penser qu elle
hallucine parce que c'est trop beau
c'est impossible sauf qu'en s'approchant
elle tend sa main et elle touche le
bateau elle se rend compte qu'il est
bien réelle en tournant la tête elle
voit qui est un chemin car l'air d'avoir
été pas mal emprunté par des hommes et
qui mène en haut d'une colline
elle utilise alors ses dernières forces
pour se rendre en haut de cette colline
et elle tombe sur une cabane et dans la
cabane se trouve un moteur de bateau et
un bidon d'essence
julian va donc siphonner l'essence et en
maître dans sa plaie ce qui va lui faire
extrêmement mal puisque le réflexe des
asticots quand tu fais ça c'est de
trouver refuge dans sa chair est donc de
s'enfoncer encore plus loin mais elle
explique qu'elle était plutôt contente
parce qu'elle a réussi à retirer au
moins 30 asticots à savoir la majorité
d'entre eux bref le soir a décidé de
passer la nuit dans la cabane mais le
sol étant trop dur elle va redescendre
la colline pour s'allonger en bas de
celle ci dans du sable et y passer la
nuit
le
demain elle se réveille sous les voies
de trois hommes elle croit à une
nouvelle fois qu elle hallucine que ça y
est elle commence à perdre la tête et
que c'est bientôt la fin mais non il ya
bel et bien trois gars qui sont en fait
des pêcheurs qui la fixe au loin et
qu'ils pensent être tombé sur un esprit
des rivières i'm just s'appelle ces
trois hommes vont donc aider julian et
ils vont tous ensemble descendre la
rivière en bateau pour rejoindre
l'hôpital local du village le plus
proche
le lendemain son sauvetage julian
retrouve son père qui était bien entendu
désespéré et elle explique que c'était
un moment particulier parce qu'ils sont
même pas parler son juste prix dans les
bras heureux de se retrouver
les gens qui suivent son père a tout mis
en oeuvre pour essayer de retrouver sa
mère parce que imaginez vous retrouvez
votre fille
dix jours après que l'appareil se soit
crashé c'est vraiment inespéré
malheureusement dix jours plus tard le
corps de sa femme a été retrouvée et
elle est décédée de la suite de ses
blessures
c'est vraiment le scénario le plus
cauchemardesque possible et c'est
vraiment arrivé à des gens et c'est
terrible donc voilà julian c'était
l'histoire de julian pareil a eu un
téléfilm
du coup sûr son histoire qui est sorti
en 2000 qui s'appelle les ailes de
l'espoir
elle a sorti un livre assez récemment
2012 qui s'appelle tomber du ciel
donc voilà si vous voulez en savoir plus
sur son histoire et l'entendre elle l'a
raconté puisque c'est son histoire c'est
pas la mienne et ben acheter ce livre
et bien voilà squeeze sa communauté ne
prirent plus jamais l'avion de leur vie
suite à cette suis vraiment pas bien on
a vu en moi j'ai des turbulences level 1
je suis le seul à suez à être pas bien à
regarder autour les hôtesses elles
rigolent en voyant d'un parent fait
cette terrible comme un crash d'avion ça
arrive peu ok mais quand ça arrive c'est
forcément la merde mais bon on est quand
même une époque où c'est très rare ça
arrive encore malheureusement mais très
rarement ya des stades drôle enfin
rassurante qui disent par exemple que tu
as beaucoup plus de chances de mourir
dans un accident de voiture sur le
trajet de l'aéroport que dans l'avion
que tu vas prendre derrière quoi bref
bah désolé ceux qui connaissaient les
histoires j'espère que j'ai bien compté
que c'était cool
il ya toutes les soixante description ci
voulais vous informer et voir tout ça
tout ce qui se dit sur sur ces histoires
là allez on arrête de chez tue c'est
fini à les regarder un truc positif là
[Musique]